all right richard i have somebody who
would love to meet you
who honestly has been so
inspired and so excited by
all that you've been doing and i think
just like the rest of the world has
um and and i think you'll be happy to
meet her i don't know you tell me
hey
hey richard
how old are you
you know what i did some years ago i
drew a picture of you and your father
oh wow your father would you hold the
enemy
yeah yeah yeah years ago in texas
yeah yeah yeah throw that picture over
someone stole that picture
well it's just my pleasure to meet you
tondo is my beautiful daughter girl
uh and she was telling me that she was
going to be doing the story on you
and i saw some of your beautiful art
and i said well i have to get one of
those paintings
so i actually i think richard you're not
charging enough money
you're not charging enough for these
paintings
i almost gave this stuff away because i
don't know how do you
yeah to be to begin to price it so i saw
something like it's like an angela davis
portrait it was like 150. so i mean
listen i'm gonna pay 1500 for that
because she needs to be at least
10 times what what you're asking for it
okay
just like i told her it's my job to
i am so proud of you i'm so proud of you
taking
your pain and turning it into promise
and
really moving that promise into a
powerful form of
expression for yourself because what i
know for sure
is that that's what all of us as human
beings are looking for
we all just want to be able to have the
truest highest expression of ourselves
and you are doing that and
i just want to encourage you to keep
doing it i'm also going to buy that
flower girl too so i'm going to pay 2
500 for her
we have the original original okay well
i want to buy her too
okay whoa yes ma'am
hey bring that over here somebody bring
me that please
[Music]
you have the original flower
wow girlfriend oh no oh
wow oh no no no no no
what what oh no no no no so what are you
selling the original for
i don't know this these guys here that's
their job
i have no idea i'm going to offer you 5
000 for her
it's yours
god bless you
she's beautiful she's original we were
just looking at the prince
yeah we looked at the kids on the
website yeah you see the flowers in her
head
she's yeah we love her she's beautiful
she's gorgeous
thank you thank you so much ma'am all
right
wonderful to see you wonderful to see
you keep doing it i look forward to
seeing
many more great artistic expressions
from you
mr richard thank you so much all right
all right bye
richard i am so happy for you
i'm so proud of you uh i i think at this
point
words are not enough to express uh the
joy that everybody feels for you um
and the joy that everybody feels for
your journey
so godspeed
to everything that's to come and
uh we wish you every success
every success
all right thank you so much you know
what
you got something coming okay you have
something coming yeah
that was just you don't even know what
you've done to my life
my family i'm sure they are ecstatic
right now
and i'm so happy thank you so much
you